ah [ __ ] herb man I mean whatever
how's it going Brad - welcome to part 4
of the wolf among us it's so hard to not
say wolf of wallstreet I swear to God I
[ __ ] hit my tooth I don't know how I
managed to do it but I had it pretty
[ __ ] hard I feel a lot better today I
fell mother than you give a [ __ ] but I
don't have fever anymore at least um
alright let's continue I should look
like it was filled with blood and shed
out frickin shadows man late evening in
the Bronx so somewhere your brows notice
that he was smoking huff and puff
cigarettes I thought I was pretty
awesome there's always a lot of details
in the shots and I think they're aware
though that their videos are popular on
YouTube say they add that stuff I don't
know want it by the hour
or for the whole night work here okay I
work the front desk it's to help pay
rent
sure so now you know I know I should
have told somebody
but beast would lose his mind if you
knew beast is a proud man big B he wants
to do right by me and he he just
couldn't handle it if he knew I had to
do this so we don't get evicted all of
our friends live at The Woodlands he
wasn't a beast though should really tell
Beast he's worried about you I will I
will I just need to in my own time [ __ ]
you right thanks for covering for me
so what are you doing here
oh you have a key
someone else was murdered she sounds
like Clementine the victim was someone
who worked at the pudding and pie Lily
she come around here ever oh oh yes the
patrol I did see her I mean you know we
never really spoke but she came off a
tad intimidating she really says it
sounds like Clementine I wonder if it's
the same act boy sector okay so why
should we ask her yeah we want to know
who Lily was whenever she Lily with
someone here maybe on a job
sometimes but nobody I've recognized I
haven't worked here that long though how
about a room register or someone named
mr. Smith that's all we get here Smiths
Jones or Johnston's I think the last
ones are jokes hmm
okay I want to ask about Tweedledee
though cuz he said they know each other
you'll de earlier today he mentioned you
in passing do you know him or his
brother I took out a loan for back pay
it was like our third notice and ever
since then those annoying freaks have
been pestering me for the money plus
interest why take out a loan from those
two it was from the crooked the crooked
man you don't know how desperate I was
Big B I had nowhere else to go
this ever happens again come see me or
snow first all right I tried really I'm
really curious about the past
cuz there seems to be a lot of like
things that happen already you know did
you know fav
have you seen snow here well I guess I
should ask laughs a girl named faith or
just maybe hear that name I might have I
don't know by the end of the night it's
kind of a blur with all the names Terra
brandy amber Heather sorry
god damn you suck man um
yeah have you seen seen snow white down
here or maybe somebody glamour dancer
exactly no it's funny I did see someone
who I thought looked a lot like her but
she didn't say anything when she saw me
even though she knew that I saw her I
just assumed it wasn't snow and went
about my business Thanks
wait it'll be better if anyone sees you
that they at least see you with me so
they know that I didn't let you just
wander around by yourself no five
minutes please so I think I have beauty
just not ready to act like I'm trying to
kick you out that won't be hard
hahaha say smash that would decide state
can I get a fresh set of top listen Big
B I assume you'll be filing some kind of
an official report or something which is
fine it's just that I was wondering if I
need to be in it do you have to mention
my name I mean it's not like beast would
ever see your report it's just well you
never know you want me to lie me to lie
not lie just not include my name just
say you talked to the clerk or something
he'll do what you have to I just want
you to know that that would help me well
here we are
which one was it
bad background noise seriously I like to
dog humping each other let's listen
he's really banging her goddamn why not
two or three I kind of want to go just
for the sake of lols I got James to
these rooms I thought you had a key
not to this one hold on baby I can't
just let you go into Indiana dammit what
someone's in there please just go
barging in we fine yeah really I didn't
I didn't think that would work
oh my god what am i doing alright hey
what the [ __ ] sorry I'm surprised he's
gonna get me fired
I need this job what's the point of that
after you might yeah do my job me not
always convenient for everyone but it
does have to be done
um okay so we wanted to go to 207
but that's listen if someone is in there
first all right this is where we want to
go 207 open this one well that's weird
this key is supposed to open every room
in the building but it's not work Judy
[ __ ] cuz that boys Oh Bea how could you
do this to me
hahahaha no wait a minute how could you
do this we've been together through
everything I took care of you I love not
what you think
please you're cheating on me with him Oh
No fils I promise I'm not I'm helping
him that's all
Oh Bert I'm sure you help each other
just great I know what this place is
I know what goes on here stop indecent
least stop this right now this isn't the
way to handle what do you know you don't
have anybody what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you she's my wife peace
to me there's nothing going on hey
master I guess I finally see you for who
you are
stop stop it I knew you were sneaking
around it's talk to your wife man like
just calm down at least
well oh well what the hell do you think
you're doing you aren't even listening
to me
looks like we're gonna have to fire them
why don't you [ __ ] listen that damn
leave it be this is my fault
shake why don't you just explain goddamn
it shouldn't be this [ __ ] hard man
that's enough man you ruined everything
she's my [ __ ] wife oh my god damn it
attack pit what have you done
Big B could you did to the door
you can't just act like this whenever
I'm back you you don't want to see this
oh damn don't make a parry joke
well the doors open now got the door
open Oh
oh my god don't touch anything is this
is this Lily met her client here mr.
Smith whoever he is and then must have
happened right here Jesus last night
yeah I was on shift last night on shift
beauty what I'm not a prostitute you
idiot I work the front desk I so that's
yeah still this is no place for someone
like you I mean look can we please not
talk about this doesn't anything out of
the ordinary there might have been some
loud noises I don't know I mean loud
noises aren't out of the ordinary
I didn't hear anyone screaming or
anything like that but shouldn't I have
it just seemed like a totally normal
night how is that even possible there's
so much blood go lock the front door
keep people out of the hallway I need
you to be sure no one comes in here this
is a crime scene okay but just do what
he says I'll explain later okay finally
if I can talk to each other free an emo
crying blood and [ __ ] baby what kind of
a person could do something like this
that's exactly what I'm about to try to
find out
so beast is the same boy so leave this
as the muslin but why don't my such man
in walking dead I can't believe I forgot
his name that I feel like an idiot do
all the rooms have these same clocks
with a built-in cassette player I think
so yes maybe they have a tape inside
them what is this what is that it's a
book about snow white or about the Mundi
version of her story anyway the Mundi
version the whole book is about her yeah
well she's popular is that Dutch why is
she in a glass coffin this is the part
where she's in a deep sleep but they
think she's dead
well I guess there's nothing more than
really we shouldn't even be in here it's
a huff and puff I thought you were the
only one who smoked that crap brand
apparently not
yeah he brought mine classy
really I don't think anything with this
hotel is classy yeah there we go
alright let's put that in yeah there we
go
alright let's put that in look at these
shots [ __ ] beautiful
like I've been like smell something no
are there something down here Apple huh
what is it
murder makes me hungry it's like the
Apple phone the fungal bite taken out of
it like in snow story oh no do you think
it was poisoned it wasn't I'd have
smelled that I think it's just a prop
it's here because they were acting out
the scene in the book of course that
makes perfect sense he's got some kind
of snow-white fixation so they come here
and play pretend I must have missed the
part of the story where he cuts her head
off though that's new sorry I shouldn't
be sorry yeah you shouldn't even be here
alright let's say I do that cuz I think
about you girl god
had this ready go in the ass I think I
heard this music last night it was
playing pretty loudly for a while and
then stopped in the middle I didn't
think twice about it at the time I mean
you hear all kinds of things around here
and I guess I've already gotten used to
blocking them out would have covered up
the sound of the murder
this music what a great murdering music
I love it alright let's see what else
evidence we can get someone's been rough
with this dress it's torn
oh no she must have been wearing it he
killed her and then and then he took it
back off why would he do that
no there's no blood on it it must have
been torn some other time maybe he likes
it rough huh hmm oh no there's more what
what now
pigby I'm thinking shut up Rhine the'm
jokes like snows coffin from the book
he's reenacted the scene with her line
here surrounded by flowers mr. Smith but
Lily to rest here you're right the bed
is the coffin he's acting out another
part of the book God I'm just having
trouble processing all of this this guy
has some kind of weird snow obsession
but then there's this other stuff too
he's into sexual violence as well as
regular violence
apparently I hope you're just about
through I don't really want to stay in
here any longer
yeah I think we're done hmm oh hello
I love the [ __ ] music man it's good
you like it dude you want to kill people
well don't do it like this guy cuz we're
gonna get him
are those pictures of the dead girl yeah
how do you know I'm in this one it was
taken last winter oh no baby
this kind of stalking it doesn't just
stop by itself trust me I know about
this firsthand he'll keep trying to get
closer and closer his stand in for snow
is gone now so the next step closer
what is it Oh crane
whoa
I call that jet I call that [ __ ] [ __ ]
I call that [ __ ] no
uh that call that [ __ ] [ __ ] cold as
[ __ ]
like he was like going and resin
[ __ ] and iam what's gonna happen now
oh no no no no no no way you know good
guys to get my hands on the disgusting
weasel
really starting to like you Sheriff
you're not afraid to be a completely
busted what obviously they will have to
make some changes
[ __ ] Lee man hello Big B and I'll got
that take care of it Big B or I'll take
care of it for you
snow is becoming a low B word and I
don't like that she scores baby
these are you yes here's my favorite
part
actually all right let's see you bros
always give me [ __ ] for making wrong
decisions so let's see how wrong I was
this time how did you respond to crate I
didn't realized there was actual
decisions in this one it flute very like
part of the stories I wasn't really like
oh yeah
[ __ ] I have a decision it's more like oh
yeah I got it now I don't know if that's
a good or a bad thing anyway how do you
respond to crane about snails death you
and 65.2 or players sympathized with him
that one was kind of vague in my opinion
I don't know there's not much to say
about that one I don't think it matters
anyway how did you treat the murder
suspect you and 65% it persuaded him to
talk oh let's say could have gone
differently huh okay that's cool did you
let's know come with you to the trip
trap yeah I mean everyone likes no
everyone wants Tara to go with you how
did you handle Georgy porgy you and 72%
Darren hit Joey holy [ __ ] I mean it's a
total Twilight I'm surprised more people
didn't hit him well [ __ ] that's awesome
that's awesome
right medical medical I love the live of
this game and I'm very glad you love it
too I think it's a it's very cool to
play these games together with you
basically in next month we're gonna get
the Walking Dead episode 2 and then the
month after that we're gonna get the the
next episode of this one that's at least
what I've heard I'm not sure how to
present sure if it's true or not but I
think that sounds pretty cool right if
we get one each month thank you boys for
watching this series as so far it's it's
far from over but still it's it's it's
very fun for me and I'm not glad you
both enjoyed it
regardless have a great have a great day
till I see you in the next video sales
impress here's an epic brofist way